Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and Merry Christmas to everyone out there.
I'm gonna be doing a quiz here that is very specifically curtailed to Christmas and
Asking you if you are ready for Christmas, so shall we begin
"How full is your jingle cave?"
*Surprised Mark*
"It's barren, without hope. Pray for my jingle cave"
"I'm trying so hard, But my humble jingle cave remains an embarrassment."
"It is a healthy amount of full. My bell pile (laughter) could be bigger."
"My grotto bursts with Christmas cheer. If it were any fuller, the geese would suffocate and the tinsel would melt and the bells would explode like shrapnel, causing a great disturbance."
Well, I mean judging by my jingle cave here,
I...I don't even have my lights up.
Aw Man, it is barren without hope. Pray for my jingle, #Pray4MarksJingleCave
"What Christmas mantra do you say over and over every day at sundown until you are dismissed?"
"Follow the star, retrieve the baby." (Laughs)
(Laughter)
"Follow the star, retrieve the baby. Follow the star, retrieve the baby."
FOLLOW THE STAR, RETRIEVE THE BABY.
"The breath of Donner sustains me; I breathe it every day"
"No enemy shall prosper, my Christmas is too strong."
(Through Laughter) "I'm a good little Christmas slut; I live in a good little Christmas hut."
(Mark Laughing)
Aw Jesus, I'm a good little Christmas slut, I live in a good little Christmas hut.
"How robust are your Christmas fantasies?"
"They are not very robust."
"They are somewhat robust, but they do not keep me from fulfilling my obligations to my job and family"
"Very robust. I am rarely cognizant of the reality around me."
"The fantasies are an all-consuming fire, swallowing me beyond escape. I am now Christmas and Christmas is me."
I go very robust because I'm always cognizant of the reality...around me...rarely.
No. Wait no, I'm never...I'm never...cognizant of reality around me.
"When the tired virgin is wheeled to your home on Christmas Eve, who will you impersonate to make her clap?"
(Concerned Mark)
I don't, I don't like the fact that I read that sentence.
"Frosty, the human soul caged in a walking snow-prison"
"Ralphie, the boy who shoots his face off with a gun"
"Grinch, the green malnourished bear"
"Polar Express, the long metal snake who takes children far away from their families" (Laughter)
I gotta be the Polar Express, I guess. Oh, that's horrible but I love it.
"Unto which list has the Red Jacket Man carved your family's name?"
"The 'Less Than 20 Mortal Sins' List"
"The 'More Than 20 Mortal Sins' List"
"The List Of Perfect Obedience To Red Jacket Man"
"The Commendable Hygiene List" (Laughter)
Well, if there's one thing that they can say about me, I do not have commendable hygiene.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna guess that I'm on the more than 20 mortal sins list.
If there's one thing you know about Markiplier, is that I have many...
*Regret*
MANY mortal sins to my name.
"Which of the merry morsels do you feed your family?"
"The turtle dove charred black on a metal skewer" ooh delicious.
"The omelet stuffed with Mentos" ooh disgusting.
"The festive gristle wreath" (Mark Laughing)
"I do not feed my family merry morsels" That I do not, I do not do that. Although I do like me a festive-
"You've unlocked the 'SuperClicker' badge!"
Uh...ah
I'm gonna go with the gristle wreath. Nah. Yes. No. Yes. No. Yes. No. Yes. No. Yes. No! Yes...
No...yes, okay.
"When the Red Jacket Man is in your house, how will you make him go away?"
"I have no plan yet."
"I will threaten to saw off the horns of his pets."
"I will shake a fearsome rattle"
"I will hide with my family in the crawl space until he is finished."
I. WILL SHAKE. MY FEARSOME BABY RATTLE!
AND HE SHALL QUIVER! *gibberish* ah whatever I'm gonna die probably to the red jacket man.
"Could you possibly believe any more if you tried?" (Laughter)
"Yes. there is doubt inside me and it brings me shame."
"No. I have taken all my vows. My belief is pristine. I would gladly die for Christmas."
"I decline to answer this question."
"Probably." (Mark Laughing)
Ah, you know if there's truth to be told, I have doubt inside me, and it brings me shame every day. Every day.
Get results...(Through Laughter) "You are not ready for Christmas."
"Oh, no. No no no. What are you thinking? Are you crazy?
'Tis the season! Don't you realize? 'Tis the season! You're letting everyone down."
AWW GAWD! I AM! I NEED TO PUT UP MY JINGLE BELLS!
*Mark singing* Oh Christmas tree, oh Christmas tree,
I do not have a Christmas tree!
*continues* Oh Christmas tree, where did you go?
I don't even have any snow!
I am LOST, without your light! God fucking damnit, the tangled lights!
*continues* Oh Christmas tree, God fuck me!
Ah, there we go...some...respite.
And there you have it
C H R I S T M A S
I'm not ready, I don't think this is enough. But it's all I have...
So thank you everybody so much for watching. Thank you for joining me on this quiz.
What's your Christmas spirit...spirit like? I'll put this quiz down in the comments-
-the description. *burp*
I'll put it down somewhere, find it, I've hidden it! hidden It away. You'll never find it!
It's somewhere down there, but if you find it...I don't think you're ready for it
So thank you everybody so much for watching! and as always, I will see you, in the next video
BUH-BYE!